el 4 de diciembre la fiscalía anunció la
disolución de la policía de la moral
Pero eso no ama y no las protestas Pues
los manifestantes aseguraban que era una
cortina de humo por parte del gobierno
cuéntenos Qué ha pasado con esa entidad
desde el anuncio
buenas noches La verdad es que
seguramente es una estrategia táctica
del gobierno para imaginar los ánimos
pero lo cierto Es que no ese no es el
tema la gente empezó pidiendo cambios en
el régimen pero ahora nos encontramos
que están pidiendo un cambio de régimen
por lo tanto ahora que la policía de la
moral no esté patrullando es el menor de
los problemas tenemos un problema de más
de 18.000 personas detenidas de las
cuales hay 10 que corren peligro de
ejecución inminente y lo que hay que
hacer es seguir siendo un altavoz de las
personas que están detenidas y exigir
juicios y garantías legales para estas
personas y como usted dice estas
protestas pasaron de pedir cambios en el
régimen a un cambio de Pero qué tan en
peligro puede estar el gobierno de
ebrahim Racing
sinceramente no es tanto
la cara visible del régimen el poder
absoluto lo tiene el líder espiritual
que no es elegido por sufragio universal
por lo tanto el problema no es tanto una
cara visible que podría dentro de dos
años en las próximas elecciones cambiar
el problema es que es todo el régimen
que ya la mayoría de la población no
quiere tenerlo Este es el kit de la
cuestión Irán la mayoría de la población
está saliendo para reivindicar derechos
humanos básicos y universales